closing arguments are set for Monday and
the manslaughter trial of a Minnesota
police officer charged in the shooting
death of a black driver during a traffic
stop
it comes after emotional testimony from
the officer who testified he was quote
scared to death here's Barry Petersen no
common among 26 witnesses to testify
over five days
officer Yana mo unis was the key witness
at his trial about what happened in a
matter of seconds in July of last year
Yana stopped falando Castille for a
broken taillight Casteel said he had a
firearm and despite being told to stay
still Yana says Castillo was pulling it
out Yanis fired seven times hitting him
with five shots
Castillo's girlfriend diamond rentals
and her daughter were in the car she
live-streamed the aftermath on Facebook
Casteel died on his way to the hospital
on the stand the 29 year old llanes was
crisp and businesslike until he
remembered that night he started to cry
I did not want to shoot mr. Castillo at
all he told the court that was not my
intention then he stopped
overwhelmed by tears on Monday there
will be closing arguments and then jury
deliberations began authorities are
already braced in the event there are
protests if Llanes walks free for CBS
this morning Saturday Barry Petersen st.
Paul Minnesota